platz nummer eins ist einfach das
unglaublichste muss ich wirklich sagen
was wie ich finde
je von ihnen welchen minecraft leuten
erschaffen wurde
beide lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge
minecraft top 5 und zwar die minecraft
top fünf maps die ich so finde und mehr
brauche ich gar nicht sagen und wir
fangen an direkt mit platz fünf wie
schnell sich einfach diese begrüße
gemacht ihr findet wie immer alle
download links und in der beschreibung
die links dazu wenn ihr euch das
anschauen wollt und zwar ist platz fünf
das hier das ist allerdings eine map die
schon extrem lange draußen und ich
möchte euch gar nicht zeigen das ganze
funktioniert weil das ein bisschen mit
redstone hier gemacht wurde sondern ich
fliege ja weil wir über damit ich schon
seht um was die map geht und zwar temple
of north cape mit sicherheit wo die paar
präsidenten da in amerika da eingelassen
wurden in sonnen in sonnenstein dings
ich glaub ich muss da unten in oder
motionen bin ich muss ihren ich glaub
ich muss oder muss ich hier hin keine
ahnung ich weiß auch nicht so richtig
wie das funktioniert mit diesen redstone
sachen weil das ganze aus einer version
ist die auf jeden fall nicht mehr
aktuelles jedenfalls ist das alter eines
spielchen der downloadlink ist wie
gesagt und in der beschreibung und man
kann halt zu gold im rhein werfen
bekommt man was raus durch die augen
entweder hoyle dieser art stempel oder
halb nicht mal schauen wie das ganze
verläuft könnte ja selbst rausziehen
allerdings fähig einfach dieses bauwerk
an school wo einfach notch in den tempel
rhein gebaut wurde bzw in so eine wand
da sieht extrem cool aus gerade wenn man
bedenkt dass das ganze zu einer zeit
gebaut wurde
wo ich weiß nicht ob es da schon world
rettet und so gab aber es sieht auf
jeden fall cool aus und es ist eine
coole inspiration und ihr müsst ihr auch
bedenken dass ich nicht einfach die maps
nehme wo einfach leute die die
heftigsten risiken sachen an bord hat
sondern auch die ideen einfach ganz gut
sind und deswegen habe ich mir genauer
guck mal da war so ein bettchen
jedenfalls habe ich mir deswegen gedacht
ist dieser nordstemmen auf jeden fall
meinen fünften platz darstellt
allerdings wollen wir natürlich alle
wissen blitzen immer einen tick aber
erstmal kommt noch platz nummer vier
platz vier belegt dass gerrit survival
und zwar ich wollte er zwei blog daran
neben allerdings ist geil ob wirklich
eine zu simple idee und zwar ihr seht
schon hier sind überall blöcke und man
kann sich quasi vorbauen ich kann jetzt
hier so hingehen dann sagen okay ich
baue jetzt diesen blog oder beispiel
zweiten schade
geht an ihren dann brauche ich diesen
blog beispielsweise ab falle darunter
falle gefangen das holz hat dann jedes
tief und kann hier mit crafting table
macht habt ihr schon mal kräftig table
kann mir dann beispielsweise mal den
kräftigen table debatte ich mach das mal
so dass ich hier hin springe kann ich
immer kurz hoch hüpfen bin ich ja das
war richtig scheiße ich denke ihr wissen
allerdings schon worum es geht
jedenfalls fünf mann von blog zu blog
und immer als unter 1 gegen einen blog
hier zum beispiel zum gremmel gerade
drauf jetzt habe ich hier noch mal holz
am start vor mir jetzt hier
beispielsweise dieser holen wir jetzt so
ein bisschen das gilt als wenig crafting
table machen wir daraus eine spitzhacke
und so was alles und die idee ist
einfach extrem galt vor allem an hat so
viele blöcke und alles verschiedenes zum
beispiel ihr seht da erwartet wobei der
grad tnt es gibt da zum beispiel sogar
tnt
hier ist ein mops porter hier sind auch
eher zäh wie gold da hinten sehe ich
emerald sich irgendwo diamanten die sind
wahrscheinlich relativ weit unten oder
diamanten sie ist wahrscheinlich
schwerer zu kommen sind links seht ihr
schon da die blöcke immer den gleichen
abstand zueinander gebaut sind ergeben
sich hier diese linien und hier solche
linien also dass die richtig krass aus
man könnte rein theoretisch so runter
laufen und alles also richtig cool
gemacht auf jeden fall ich bin jetzt
natürlich tot geboren ich wieder hier
oben ist eine richtig geile and
management ist ist einfach auf platz
vier wegen der idee weil die idee ganz
geil ist und deswegen würde ich einfach
sagen dass mein platz ist okay aber
gucken jetzt völlig beispielsweise
auserwählt und ihr seht ihr merkt wie
geil das ganze aussieht und wie viele
blöcke da überhaupt am start sind
das kann man echt extrem geil sehen wenn
ich einfach mal aus der welt trotz falle
der braucht einfach so lange mein pc um
das alles zu verarbeiten jetzt gebt euch
das mal wie viele blöcke da am staaten
alter das ist richtig krank
jedenfalls ist das deswegen mein heck
nummer vier mit platz vier
und jetzt wackelt wieder alles sorry das
ist merkel der neue mann david sind dann
ist wahrscheinlich schon da habe ich mir
noch immer vor produzieren
und ja das war platz vier tut mir leid
wenn man das merkt aber ich bin einfach
mega übermüdet aber ich möchte einfach
nicht dass ihr über weihnachten und sein
war gar keine videos haben weil ich
kenne selber damals ich vor fünf jahren
als ich irgendwie so 14 war oder so um
den dreh habe ich mir auch so gehalten
vor langweilig können so youtuber nicht
mehr hochladen
aber ich verstehe natürlich total ich
meine das macht mir spaß machen ford
zuständig bin einfach müde
ich will mich freuen das respektieren
würde wenn ich hier mit ein bisschen
übermüdet oder total so abgefragt bin
oder so aber ich möchte jetzt auf jeden
fall euch jetzt mal den platz nummer
drei zeigen und zwar das new york ich
mach mal eben auch times hätten 0 damit
das ganze am tag stattfindet und ich
nehme auch eventuell mal einfach das
backstage schmeckt damit das ganze ein
ganz klein bisschen cooler aussieht und
jetzt muss ich natürlich ganzen tag
erstmal warten also ich war noch nie in
new york ich kann jetzt nicht sagen ob
das ganze detailgetreu ist oder nicht
aber was ich sagen kann ist natürlich es
ist alles nicht per hand gemacht worden
das wird natürlich world daran geholt
aber ich finde es immer krass so städte
in minecraft weil ich denke mal wenn ich
durch die stadt fahren wenn ich von
hamburg ich mich nach hause fahre oder
mal nach köln oder so denke ich mir
einfach immer so bauer
diese ganze stadt und so wenn man das
kannst du deine heimat in minecraft
nachbaut würde wäre das extrem kreis und
das ist jetzt wahrscheinlich wirklich
new york und wirklich leute sind hier
dann hergelaufen das ist in minecraft
einfach nachgebaut
das finde ich extrem cool hier auch
wahrscheinlich häuser die reise nicht
kennt ihr die in new york waren
irgendwie gleich wissen die dass er oder
das was das hier für häuser was ist das
hier was ich da richtig zäh los mit dem
wir das könnte doch nee ich hab keine
ahnung ob das dass das ist nicht das
empire state building
ich weiß nicht ob es zu der zeit
gebaut wurde er was habe ich natürlich
dass ein paar merk ich bin müde aber
hier die kirche kommt auf jeden fall
bekannt aus einigen filmen
es ist auf jeden fall richtig geil und
es wird richtig viel hier hinzugefügt
man hier hinten ist auch wieder riesig
geiles hochhaus es sieht einfach mega
geil aus alles also ich muss echt sagen
respekt an die leute die das gemacht
haben und das ist auf jeden fall mein
platz nummer drei und jetzt kann man
platz findet ihr eigentlich dass das so
zu lange ist was ich immer zu irgend
sondern einzelnen sache bei dieser top 5
serie rede oder auch bei den kräftigen
ideen weil ich finde einfach wenn ich
nur sagen würde ja das ist das und das
und bleibt dann wäre es zu kurz aber
wenn ich so ganz arbeit aus wohl immer
darüber was er zehn eigene story damit
verbinde denke ich mir auch immer so
hilft vielleicht findet ihr das ein
bisschen zu landen
aber ich würde sagen wir kommen auf
jeden fall jetzt platz nummer zwei und
zwar kann ich mich hier nicht in den
games befördern sondern weil da steht da
du hast nicht die benötige berechtigung
diesen befehl auszuführen muss mich erst
op maria jetzt keine lust drauf
jedenfalls ist es soweit gameone weide
war idol arno und zwar ich hab das extra
über das manhattan project gestellt dass
new york was platz drei war weil das
einfach ich find's einfach viel
imposanter
das hat einfach diese start sind so
geheimgänge drin das new york project
ist zwar auch mega geil und so aber das
hier ist halt wirklich so da hast du zum
beispiel hier hinweis ich hast du so ein
geheimgang kannst du so drumrum hoch
springen weil wir haben damals auch die
zuwahl begrenzter gezockt und alles hier
kannst du auch so hoch hüpfen und die
ganze klasse ich glaub ich mit dem team
deutschland mit dem team damals oder so
ich weiß nicht mehr genau
jedenfalls sind die extrem coole sache
noch dazu gebaut einfach so so easter
eggs so dass man daneben wo christen
findet ich weiß zum beispiel auch noch
ganz genau diese mac geht nahezu gar
nicht auf irgend welchen servern
angeboten obwohl ich immer noch findet
allerbeste sowie games pepper weil das
wirklich dieses so eine veranstaltung
feeling und alles ich weiß nur dass sie
hinten so ein kleines dorf war und so
mit zu kleinen garagen und so also finde
ich einfach nur mega cool gemacht alles
ich kann jetzt leider nicht im game und
1 herumfliegender zeigen euch leider
keine berechtigung aber wenn man sich
das auch hier beispielsweise mal anguckt
wie hat man also häuser mit
irgendwelchen garagen as safe die
blätter sind so richtig schilder jetzt
musste hier beispielsweise bis dahin
weggefangen da sind so auch so richtige
schilder wollte auch wirklich was drauf
steht so dollar locker und so was alles
alles wirklich mit liebe zum detail
gemacht mit von bereit und seinem team
und auch einfach diese hochhäuser da
hinten einander gestützt sind finde ich
wie viel krasser als das in new york das
manhattan project wo die ganzen sache
übereinander nur mit world sind hier
wirklich nur zum hier fühlt man sich
echt wie so ein kleiner knabe der in dem
hochhaus finde ich echt mega geil diese
map und will ich würde diesen weg
nämlich noch eben langlaufenden die cool
man kann hier soll einen weg lang laufen
sie davon hochhaus dieses riesige
kolosseum ding mit dieser abgebrochenen
nadel da oben dran
find ich einfach nur geil könnte
eigentlich einmal platz nummer 1 1
allerdings jetzt kommt erst mal platz
eins und platz nummer eins einfach das
unglaublichste muss ich wirklich sagen
was wie ich finde
je von irgendwelchen minecraft leuten
erschaffen wurde und zwar ist es
imperial city ihr seht schon wenn ich
mich mal umdrehen das ist nicht einfach
new york oder irgendwie so das ist auch
nicht einfach nur so weit wie games zwei
maps sondern es vereinbart ist nämlich
und zwar hier sind richtig viel auf
details geachtet sodass hier so kleine
gebäuden da stehen und auch mit mit so
kleinen mit zur tischen vor und mit
sitzmöglichkeiten da kannst du hier
runter gehen kannst du eine u-bahn
laufkatze hier so rumlaufen kann
zuschauen
ok guck mal da steht das gebäude hier
stehen dann die bürger hier ist auch so
alles schön hier sind auch so schilder
und alles mögliche geil am start
ich kann immer im creative rumlaufen und
ihr seht schon sieht das geil aus
freunde sieht das geil aus ich kann ja
einfach mal also wie findet ihr den
download link in der beschreibung unter
ist ein foto von ganz oben von der web
hochladen
ihr seht schon denke ich wie das ganze
so in etwa aufgebaut ist inwiefern das
ganze ganz geile sie sieht man jetzt
rechts im bild diese riesige kirche
allein schon ihr seht ihr dieses ganze
das erinnert mich so heftig an
assassin's creed alltag in assassin's
creed würze jetzt denkt okay kommt hier
hoch klettern dann hier hochklettern
hier so drüber springen
sondern ganz runter gucken längst als ok
attentate template oder schaut euch mal
hier
das ist so eine spinne die dargestellt
wurde oder hier so dinosaurier hier ist
einfach so ein mammut beispielsweise
können wir mal weiter hierdurch fliegen
dann haben wir hier autos und innenhof
haben wir hier noch alle möglichen
sachen sofort riesiges hier auch mega
pompös aufgebaut hier so ähnlich wie der
wie das dings in paris ja das nicht der
louvre sondern auch nicht der auch ihr
wisst was ich meine schreibt mir mal
wieder das heißt da kann man auch drauf
gehen dieses ding da stehen auch in
paris hier auch megageil alles gemacht
guck mal hier mit der mit der mit dem
weißen gebäude hier und so das ist
wahrscheinlich irgendwie ja etwas jura
in sondern recht sprechen das ding
richtig geil kann man auf jeden fall auf
rein weil innen drin auch richtig viel
liebe zum detail überall alles geil
gebaut das wort da saßen die mehrere
monate wenn nicht sogar jahre richtig
geil gemacht schaut euch das hier allein
mal an dieses gebäude
ich denke dass das zeigt schon echt was
das hier für eine geile map ist und das
ist zu recht der platz nummer 1 finde
ich guck mal hier oben
wie hoch ich einfach schon bin und es
geht immer noch höher weil ihr diese
kuppel ist alter sogar durch die wolken
durch schaut mal hier und hier oben
immer noch auf details geachtet dass
hier oben alles stimmt gehe ich mal hier
oben durch damit ihr seht wie das ganze
aussieht eine luftballon und ich habe
zehn jahre weiter reden imperial city
ist für mich dass minecraft projekt
microsoft nap nummer eins auf oldtimer
ladet euch runter unterstützt die leute
was ist da dann links ist auch schön ja
sowas riesiges wie kürzlich auf windows
taste gekommen hier ist noch größere
kathedrale als dieses ding da schon ist
alter das sieht ja schon mega pompös
aber guckt euch das mal an die junge
alter also ich könnte die ganze zeit
schwärmen
ladet euch einfach mal die sachen runter
die in der beschreibung findet ich würde
mich mega freuen wenn ihr das video mit
einer bewertung bewerten würde also ich
würde auf jeden fall sagen ich jetzt
kennen weil ich bin müde aber ich möchte
euch trotzdem videos liefern und dann
sehen uns in den anderen video wieder zu
übrigens teure reihenfolge würde die
auch sein dass es platz eins ist das für
euch erstgerät platz 1 oder irgendwie so
einfach die kommentare